it's been a tough year for stocks and  bonds around the world but there's one  investment that really stands out  private golf club memberships in  Singapore  values for memberships at clubs like  Sentosa have more than doubled in the  last two years alone that means for  locals they've got to pay the equivalent  of about 350 000 US dollars to join for  expats like me it's more like six  hundred thousand dollars there's a  couple reasons behind the surge there's  just been a general increase in interest  in golf during the pandemic but more  importantly there's been a surge of  wealthy foreigners coming to Singapore  the long lockdown in China made a lot of  people wants to come to Singapore they  really love our lifestyle you know our  freedom  I think most of them are here doing some  business we are quite happy that they're  coming and investing here they buy  membership and they're putting a lot of  money on golf lessons which is very good  for the game  [Music]